Jessica starts off this hour in Houston
Texas hi Jessica how are you hi thank
you protect my call Dave
sure what's up in your world well I had
a situation at Christmas and it's
actually been going on for quite some
time and I don't know what to do at this
point I have a pretty large family and
my mom gives very generously and when I
say generously she will spend two to
three thousand dollars on each person
Wow and yeah and it's pretty outrageous
and for the last couple of years I would
say probably the last six years I give a
very modest list when she asked for a
Christmas list and I'm saying pedicure
or something you know really small and
she this year I didn't give her a list
at all and she bought me a very
extravagant gift that cost over $8,000
that she is having to make payments on
she doesn't have the money no no she
does not she does not have the money to
do it she does have the money but she
spins it when she gets it
so when it comes Christmas time she does
not have the money so these people are
not not multi gazillionaires then okay
no no not at all and I am I've been
following your plan since 2011 and I am
debt free and I'm I'm probably somewhere
near baby steps 6 6 to 7 and I have the
money to pay off this gift outside of my
all of my retirement funds outside of my
emergency fund and I have a separate
savings account where I do have enough
to pay it off and I just what is the
gift returnable no it's not it's it's a
type of a vehicle and and that was the
very first question I asked her after
Christmas settled down about a week
after I let her know how much I very
much appreciate it but that I would like
to pay half and I didn't want I said
please don't answer me now I'd like you
to think about it but I'd like to pay
half of this off
she didn't answer me about a week went
by and we had another discussion and it
got extremely heated why she told she
well I asked her again if I could pay
half of half of it off she told me that
it made her angry that she couldn't just
accept this gift and I told her I said
look I do your finances I know what your
income is
I know what your outgo is and I
appreciate the gift but it's just
ridiculous and is your dad in the
picture no no they've been divorced
since I was young and here's the problem
okay um this is not about you um your
mom is ill she told me I was ill no
there's okay I have a problem with money
this is a mental illness and the way we
know that is is that the the scale of it
and the absurdity of it it's so extreme
mean to you it feels like it's out of
line to me it sounds like she's off the
ranch it's a burden to me no I'm not
worried about you mark I'm not worried
about you I'm worried about her I think
she's sick I think she's got some kind
of issue from the divorce or from the
way she was raised at her wiring got
short-circuited I mean this is what
Jessica whacked I mean you're broke and
you give an $8,000 gift
among other two thousand three thousand
dollar gifts at Christmas that you have
to finance and then you're angry about
someone feeling weird about that
this is she she's got a wiring problem
she told me I took the joy out of her
gift giving she doesn't have a joiner
gift giving she's she's sick she needs
counseling a Headley I might not
disagree with you that's my opinion now
how do you when you have a relative that
you love that doesn't think that they
have some emotional or mental
issues they don't think they have any
but we know they need counselling what
can we do well we're up a creek we can't
make adults do smart things but I think
that's the way you need to start viewing
this of as your mom is ill like it like
she was doing cocaine or she was
drinking so much that she couldn't get
out of bed you know she's got an illness
and she needs to an addiction a wiring
short-circuit and again just slightly
extravagant things or one thing and many
of us do that I've I you know I had one
of my kids go back off
Papa Dave your your your gift to the
grandkids is out of control because hey
kids are great but I don't know how
great grandkids are I'd have been nicer
to their parents you know so I mean I I
can be accused of this but I don't have
a mental illness and I can respect the
boundary when one of my grown kids says
you know you need to back it off Papa
Dave you dialed it up about six notches
too far I was just having fun about half
a Toys R Us but but that's a little you
can't I can and it's a tiny tiny
percentage of my world but it was out of
line even for the kid
the kids had so much that they were
stressed and it was more I have a son
and he is seeing this and I'm very
modest at Christmas in my own house it's
just me and my son and I'm very modest
because I am following your plan I don't
think there's a need for extravagance
and he loves what I give him he can't
wait to play with whatever I give him
and he follows your plan and I think if
you'll just reset your mind on how
you're dealing with your mom of this is
not a discussion with a rational person
this is a discussion with someone who is
struggling and doesn't even know they're
struggling I do have one sibling out of
several that feels the same way I do so
what we'd like for Helders mom she's in
our 70s and she works okay mom you're in
your seventies you work you know a lot
of money we're really worried about you
would you consider sitting down with a
pastor or counselor and unpacking some
of this with them talking to them about
why you're giving like this because
truthfully
you know I talked to a professional
financial coach and he thinks you need
to see a counselor and you can blame it
on me because I just say that you know
well you know the chances are we're
doing it I got to tell you our very low
because this one was also angry and she
probably going to get an angry response
yeah I got a very angry response in fact
I took notes when this whole conflict
happened and and she is kind of like an
elephant in the room where I feel like
I'm dancing around something but if it's
every day or every day and every day it
feels like and it almost feels normal
yeah you're going to have to make this a
big deal I mean if she was doing cocaine
how would you treat it it's kind of
weird to talk about a seven-year-old
doing cocaine but some of them do but I
mean if she was doing something bizarre
addictive strange behavior how would you
handle this with your 72 year old mother
it's it's a very imperfect process and I
think if you start viewing it through
those eyes instead of like you're the
daughter trying to you know dance around
this thing I'm not dancing around it
driving a truck through it this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh